actually yeah but but you'd have to do
that with software you wouldn't be doing
that with just it might make some way
and not with just the micro oh that's
the worst but you think you're [ __ ]
getting the line and he's like yell
something at them but then when you're
in the line you realize all you hear is
yeah he's been your [ __ ] yeah what'd he
say you yeah you'd have to actually get
your body out the window and yell uh-huh
otherwise the sounds just coming out in
a weird way weird boxy pattern remember
dirty work dirty work the movie um yeah
with the arm and Artie yeah that's that
to a line if I could moons them he wants
a line Artie and that needs it pulls
over Artie's like I was uh supposed to
keep driving sorry everybody
did you see the pictures of Artie Benoit
saying already haven't same around his
nose is all [ __ ] up it's caved in well
I guess he snorted something and he had
an infection
Oh makes sense his nose was huge it was
weird yeah it's pretty big
he said it's like wow yeah right there
oh yeah that one yeah what is going with
the Artie Lange's nose yeah something's
happening he's such a good guy he's
great yeah he's a really good pool
player is it really I could believe that
he's real good
he's more than anybody like refused to
accept that he's famous so he just like
walks around normal and then people
start recognizing oh yeah I think kind
of like goes away but like yeah he just
goes into normal environments all the
time he's a good dude
he really is really good guy you know he
is not making twenty twenty I don't
think so no way no no desire to quit
he's just he's riding it out did he quit
for a while I think every once in a
while I don't really know I think every
once a while like he gets clean from
reading but it's like he doesn't really
why just wants to pull it back a little
sometimes right he's never gonna be one
of the guys like yeah I haven't touched
the stuff in five years yeah I don't
think he's interested in that he's
enjoying himself
that's a Mitch Hedberg said before he
died apparently they were trying to get
him to clean up he's like I'm not doing
[ __ ] I like it
yeah it's like when you tell people quit
smoking like what why I'm not desire and
quitting right now you guys are
yeah that's a hard pill for people to
swallow that don't do it yeah you know
like oh yeah just quit you should just
quit dude when you see those gackt out
people on the sidewalk in New York you
know just [ __ ] standing up you know
dosed out or something like that or just
like you know nodding off in their own
whatever take day time you're like wow
they are [ __ ] up but now that I've
done enough drugs you realize like
they're loving it right now they are
having the best time they're peaking
it looks shitty but they're peaking when
they come to [ __ ] in their pants and
nowhere to go all right the best but
right I don't know Milken Superbowl
tweaking yeah their experience is
amazing yeah they're they're hearing
Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds Oh